ce sont les jours qui m'ont
manqué
donne moi le goût donne moi le jus de
mon vin
ce sont les jours qui apportent ton
sens
je sens le calme du soleil et je me
sens bien
parfois quand les lumières se ferment
tôt
je  souviens toi quand je commence à sourire
même si maintenant tu ne veux pas
me connaître  de rêves sans fin
les ennuis de la vie s'envolent
comme une brûlure
ce sont les jours
mon
peut-être que ça n'a pas marché
mais nous avons fait de notre mieux
ce sont les jours qui me manquaient
donne moi le goût  donne-moi la joie du
vin d'été
ce sont les jours qui m'apportent
je me sens encore souffrir une chanson que
je sais
faire
et je
me sens
bien
toi